what's my hot take on the Israel
Palestine conflict what's my just
shooting from the hip totally going to
cut to the heart of things take my take
is it's very complicated some people
however think it's really really simple
and so they're giving their 60-second
hot takes I keep getting comments that
if I was in Gaza I would be killed for
being queer and first off there are
queer people in Gaza and they're being
killed for being Palestinian secondly I
don't need to move across the ocean to
experience violence for being queer I
literally had to evacuate my place 6
months months ago because people were so
violent and sending me death threats
literally hunting me down for being
trans I will never stand by Israel's
actions I won't stand by Israel in
general and if you're queer and you are
standing with Israel you're wrong and
you really need to take a step back and
evaluate your morals and values this
individual has a little bit of a point
which is that the reason that BLM and
antifa and the queers for Palestine and
all these people support Hamas over
Israel is because Israel is a stand in
in their minds for Western
Civilization you know the libs love
talking about science and how great
science is so I would just test that
thesis with an experiment which is I
would just recommend that the the queers
for Palestine go visit the Gaza Strip
but they won't do it because they know
they'll get thrown off a rooftop so they
they're admitting by not going to visit
the Gaza Strip and by never ever being
willing to do that they're recognizing
that what they're saying is not true and
what we're saying is Right which is all
I really wanted in the first place so in
the United States we have the Second
Amendment which states a well-regulated
militia being necessary to the security
of a free state the right of the people
to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed so essentially the whole
purpose is to revolt against a
government that's oppressing its people
right like if I'm misunderstanding
please correct me but okay I'll put a
pause there I I will correct you it's
it's self- protection my guns iway I
started
blasting it is for at a very personal
sense stopping people from murdering you
or from burglarizing your home and then
at a community sense it's for protecting
the not only your family but the
collection of families living around you
and then the highest political sense yes
it's to be able to protect yourself from
enemies foreign and domestic that's true
so this woman is seriously
oversimplifying it so why do people
support the Second Amendment but then
call Hamas terrorists just think about
that what you just said is one of the
most insanely idiotic things I have ever
heard
Hamas targets civilians which is what we
commonly call terrorism and we support
the Second Amendment because people have
a right to self- protection so what
brings you here today to support
Palestinian rights we as Jews are
embarrassed what's happening there in
the state of Israel in the Jewish name
and what's your message to the people of
Palestine they shouldn't give out the
struggle they should continue to fight
and not give up the struggle against the
state of Israel because by the by by the
end Palestine will be free because this
is truth yeah this video is pretty
interesting to me because it's a hidic
Jew and there are a lot of hidic Jews
who oppose the nation state of Israel
just as there have been Jews throughout
history for 150 years who have opposed
Zionism that guy seems to be proving my
point which is that it's a very
complicated issue when you want to
protect your data you've got to go to
expressvpn.com
YT as you know there are a lot of people
we want to look at what you are doing
online the government the isps the big
tech companies they all are digging into
your stuff and so you should use the
number one rated VPN on the market
expressvpn head on over there right now
we've got all sorts of great deals and
promos if you are a listener and a
viewer of this show do not wait you got
to go immediately over to
expressvpn slm letter y letter T that is
expressvpn.com
slm YT today it is so important for
queer people to support Palestine and
I'm sure you've been seeing all this
Discord from queer people who are not
Muslim but as someone who is Muslim um
listen to me especially if you grew up
in a Muslim household you can
acknowledge that Palestine may not have
had the best policies towards gr people
but you can also acknowledge that
Palestine is one of the most Progressive
Nations on the planet considering what
they have been through Palestine is just
like other Muslim countries when it
comes to queer policies yeah they could
have had much better policies not to
mention there are so many queer people
in Palestine take a look at queering the
map okay there are so many stories of
queer Palestinians and if that does not
resonate with you I don't know what else
to like tell you like I don't know how
to create empathy within you for these
people there are a lot of stories about
queer Palestinians there there are a lot
of fables about a lot of people but but
the point he's making here is fair
enough which is the fact that Palestine
is prod dominantly Muslim and enforces
this fairly brutal vision of Islam the
fact that they thereby don't support
queerness is used as a political cudel
against Palestinian statehood when in
fact the same thing is true of any
number of Muslim countries in the region
but generally speaking yeah that's true
they they've got a more conservative
sexual ethic throughout uh a lot of the
the Arab states centering this issue
with queer people guys it is not about
queer people it's about Palestinian
liberation and that includes queer
Palestinians go show support for
Palestine yes that is what it is about
and so that that's why BLM and antifa
and queers for Palestine and Hamas are
somehow all on the same team here is
there're all uh rebelling against norms
and traditions of the power that has
dominated the globe for recent memory
and for the modern era which is the west
and ironically that that very notion of
Liberation is an unfortunate product of
the West be very careful of what you say
about Israel any believer going against
Israel you are making yourself an enemy
against God if the US and the European
nations are so for Israel they should
give them land from Europe or land from
the United States to live on they should
let them make a country there not on
Palestine the Bible does not say
anything about Israel because Israel was
created in 1948 when the British and the
United Nations decided to fight a war
with Palestine and cut that country in
half to create an ethn state for
ashkanazi Jewish people so the first
lady I guess is arguing a perspective
known as
dispensationalism which is a a view very
prominent among American Evangelical
Protestants the argument that there is a
distinction between Israel and the
church which is contrary to the
traditional view which is that the
church is the the new Israel that is the
continuation of Israel and then uh the
lady comes in to disagree with the first
lady and she says this is is BS man the
Palestinians have been in the land since
before time and they have the
Nationalist right to to this land and
you say well why is that the case why do
the Palestinians why do the Palestinian
Muslims have it Islam didn't even exist
until the 7th Century so why do they get
the right to the Holy Land and this This
Woman's answer would obviously be well
because they conquered it okay well then
what about the state of Israel you're
saying that well the state of Israel is
unjust cuz they came into the holy land
and conquered it in 1948 all right but
you implicitly grounded the right of the
Palestinian Muslims to have the
territory on the the very same right of
Conquest so now it looks like there's a
double standard and this lady just
doesn't want there to be a Jewish State
there or anything okay how's that did
that clarify anything probably not
probably not very much because it's a
very complicated issue I'm Michael NS is
the Michael no show see you next
time head
terrorist terrorize
[Music]
this